this has been your first real press tour
with all this group what is it like with
all these this whole gang of folks
I mean it's wild it's hard to I don't
know if you're able to get shots of like
the magnitude of where we are but
there's nothing like it there's nothing
like it there's no movie like it there
are a lot of stars are you finally happy
to see this movie yes it's been years I
don't know what the movie is I have no
idea what's gonna happen so I'm excited
to see it do you remember yourself
people don't realize you were in 13
going on 30
I remember it was like the moment when I
realized that I really wanted to direct
I remember paying a lot of attention to
where the camera was and the camera
moves thinking about how I would have
cut it together and then seeing the
movie and seeing how it differed from
what I thought so the French Chuck is
now gone viral what he what is it about
the French Chuck and Hugh tot Oprah the
French sucks I can't believe I had the
opportunity to teach over the French
stock I mean really it's tan tan is the
one who brought it all to the table so
I'm just happy to be able to share his
work
[Music]